foreign
's with us in Lansing Michigan hey Sam
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you guys today great how can
we help
so
um my wife uh informed me a couple weeks
ago that she was 23 24 000 in credit
card debt without me knowing over the
course of the last year
and I was wondering what would be the
best way to pay it off we have a couple
options
um I got lucky rather be lucky than good
I won 36 000 at the casino
um but that money I already
um about a month ago and I already had
that money tied up in Money Market
because I'm using that for the down
payment on my next home
um we could cash in her 401K which is 25
000 in it and pay it off
or do we just
um kind of suck it up and just make the
payments and just pay it down month by
month
um I just wondering what the best option
would be to avoid the interest payments
and everything like that yeah
you realize the interest payments aren't
the real problem in your house right
uh how long have you been married how
long have you been married
so we have been married for a year and a
half now okay and how long has she had
this debt
um a year it started
um basically when my son was born a
little bit over a year ago and it was
just uh online ordering
stuff like that three different credit
cards going shopping kind of thing and I
never really noticed that we have
separate finances and I never really
noticed it because we don't have any
debt you know other than our house
so how's that working for it
oh it was working fantastic up until a
couple weeks ago I don't think it is do
you
no not been work it's not been working
for some time like ever in your married
life it just was revealed it was just
revealed a couple weeks ago
correct yeah you all are not on the same
page
not at all also she's spending as a
coping mechanism
she she's there's something that she's
trying to cope with and she's not doing
it in a healthy way and so she's looking
to spending and so she Revenge spending
because you're gambling
I don't gamble that I that was the
second time I had been at the casino in
five years
what'd you spend
and did you budget for it or did you
just go and do it on a whim
uh we just did we just did it we just
did it out of whim basically
okay
and oh well all right so
um
I think the thing that number one when
we're meeting when we're researching
millionaires
one of the things we find
typically among the and we've done the
largest study of millionaires ever done
Sam uh is that the husband and wife are
working together
and there aren't secrets and there is
not impulsive spending and uh the number
of millionaires in our study that became
millionaires in casino is precisely zero
the number of millionaires in our study
whose wife or husband hides their
finances from them because they don't
have good communication is precisely
zero so those are the things that
concern me more than the actual credit
card debt do you see what I'm saying
yes I do so if you guys want to prosper
and do extremely well which is our goal
to help you because we love you we want
you to win uh it would entail combining
your finances only one checking account
and a budget meeting every month that
the two of you sit down together both of
you have a vote some reason she doesn't
think she's got a vote she had to hide
it from shame or guilt or something and
we've got to rebuild trust which has
been violated here and the two of you
together she has a vote you have a vote
we are in agreement about what our
future goals are and where we're going
from there
and so
um you don't agree with this but I'm
going to tell you what I think okay
because you called here I think you both
did something stupid and the only good
news is it cancels out
I think you got lucky instead of losing
a pile of money you came home with a
pile of money that's the worst thing
that can happen at a casino because
you're so dumb then you go back again
thinking you're that guy and so I'm
cashing this money out paying off these
credit cards we're going to combine our
finances and we're going to set a goal
or we're very diligent very steady not
flashy to save up a down payment for a
home together and meantime whatever
spending we're going to do that is
reasonable spending the two of us are
going to be in agreement every single
month before the month begins and not
following through on that you or her is
lying to your spouse
and uh so what she did here is not cute
it's not funny and what you did here is
not cute and it's not funny it can be
devastating if it's extended out and
forward both of them can be and so I you
know I I'm fussing at you because I love
you and I want you to win but if you
were my kid and you're 30 years old this
is exactly how I would talk to you and
what I would tell you as your friend
um not because I'm your dad but because
I love you and because I want you to win
and so
uh
Sam if you haven't had in our world we
call what she did Financial infidelity
yeah because it activates the same place
in you that sexual infidelity does
because it's a violation of trust yeah
to run up 24
000 and destroy or rather delay your
dream of buying a home because of
financial misbehavior yeah and a lie
yeah and to be honest if I'm in their
situation I'm probably going to seek out
some counseling some marriage counseling
yeah because they're they're early on
and and this is not they're still
forming that that foundation and this is
not the sort of thing that you want in
the foundation you want to get to the
bottom of this find out why you guys are
keeping secrets find out why she's
feeling neces feeling it's necessary to
medicate by spending and and possibly
same for you same I and I think if I
were in your shoes and I was 24 and some
guy said to me what I just said to you I
would have a tendency to blow it off
like you're overreacting Dave you're
overstating this and what I'm saying is
is these two things
these three things not working together
hiding and lying about money and
gambling are three things that will
cause you to not become a millionaire so
this is like a million dollar discussion
that's why this is important so I'm not
overreacting because even though it's
only twenty four thousand and thirty six
thousand it's small in the in the scope
of Life what the the behaviors are going
to prohibit you or delay you at minimum
from becoming wealthy to the tune of
millions and millions of dollars so this
is a this is a I'm not overreacting
because this is millions of dollars
we're talking about absolutely over time
yeah Dave you're being kind because this
this this is a big deal to me I mean if
Sam warshaw if I found out Sam warshaw
went behind my back and spent twenty
five thousand dollars
there'd be an atom bomb that went off
you would see the explosion I'm just
saying there'd be a little little fire
there'd be Birds little birds chirping
around his head because I would have
knocked him out
so but I I kind of think it might been
more likely you that would do that than
him though
you know what that's probably true
because I am the spender he is he is a
saber he's Mr deliberate yeah he is
which is even more reason if he did that
I would have gone off on him but it's
it's what you said these little things
it makes me think of that that scripture
that says a little eleven the only time
that we've even come close to that at
our house and we did come in the early
days we had lots of arguments about
money in fights was when I was so
overbearing I know you can't imagine
that happening that Sharon didn't feel
like she had a vote
yeah and she will tell you at about year
seven of our marriage she felt like she
got her voice yeah is the way she says
it and she never lost it since I'll just
tell you but um but her voice but I got
my voice and um and yeah but it was she
got her vote yeah and uh and and from
then on she's kind of had two but um to
make up for the Lost Years but that's a
thing if you don't feel like you're you
have a a voice in the thing or you can't
make a lot you can't you can't get there
in a discussion then one spouse tends to
go off and hide stuff and do things and
that's not an indication it's not a
money problem that's a relationship
that's right that's right relationship
problem and it wasn't it wasn't my house
too Sam I'm just admitting just like you
but I'm just old and it was a long time
ago that's the only difference so
um don't be mad at us we love you that's
why we're picking on you but I would fix
those things in my house because they're
costing you over the rest the scope of
the rest of your life millions of
dollars if you don't fix them